what do you guys want to hear a rap
about engineers that feels very kind of
covered already very very thoroughly
maybe we should give other professions
or other words a go
hr oh we are really asking with
professions are you in hr
yeah what's your
what's your favorite what's your
favorite thing about hr
what okay i don't think that should be
your favorite thing someone comes in
crying like what's the problem i was
sexually harassed oh goody yay
more work for me okay sexual harassment
as part of your job
as a human resources individual wow
um don't go work for her company or do
depending on your tastes
right let's come to if you're in this
kind of triangular section here that i'm
carving out what you want to hear a rap
about
money okay i feel that's actually
there's so many hip-hop songs about
money so
no um you know there's not many hip-hop
songs about
the impact of sexual harassment and hr
in the workplace
i feel like 25 percent of rap songs are
about money
uh i don't mind that it's just like you
know i feel like if i ever did a wrap
song about money
it's you know like well it's not as fun
so welcome to give another one
jousting okay cool yeah that's better
thank you
see if you give a boring suggestion i
will push you for a better one
jousting i like that jousting sexual
harassment in hr
let's come to the front of this room
here what do you want to wrap up
who said pickleball yeah yeah
did you know that jack cohen who was on
earlier is a pickleball champion
yeah yeah they're the handsome guy with
the gray hair with the pine yeah
him and his wife they they just won in
the 60 to 65
4-0 division which is actually quite
good right yeah
they were in the three fives they got up
to 401 and gold everyone else is like
we've no idea what pickleball is
i'm a big fan of pickleball i played it
once and i really enjoyed it
because i have very low cardiovascular
fitness pickleball
pickleball sexual harassment in hr
jousting
let's come to the kind of middle to back
of the room back in the room i'll come
to you afterwards but middle
super hero okay let's pick a specific
one
so wait what did someone over there said
something though wonder woman and you
said spike these feel very
obvious can we not go a bit more niche
mascots aren't superheroes
yeah they are that's said by someone who
is a mascot they're like it's a hot
costume chris it's uh okay yeah mascot
superheroes i'm happy with that
and and right at the back of the room
what do you want to wrap that's the
final suggestion so make it good
my daydream i don't daydream as a person
i'm afraid i have a very focused mind
but i'm keen to know what when you
daydream what do you dream of
[Music]
[Laughter]
vacation okay and your your vacation
daydream
where would that be too
oh yeah yeah everyone else like to say
shells yeah yeah
i was just checking in case i don't know
maybe they changed their name in the 24
hours since
sachel now okay tropical daydreams of
sachal
uh mascot superheroes pickleball hr
sexual harassment and jousting cool
those are some great suggestions
and this to close out the show lovely
people uh of the comedy of magic club
it's going to be a little freestyle that
don't i'll stand up for it um this will
be a freestyle it's a wrap made up on
the spot based in town the suggestion
never be seen again don't worry it won't
be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly bad as you're expecting a
privately educated middle class white
point of view
if you can drop that beat my friend
let's do this
[Music]
this is quite a high energy beat i
forgot i brought this one today
cool this can be good um
let's start with yours it seems a cool
stuff kick it off yeah
i'm so thrilling i'm hitting all the
targets i'm making sure i'm tilting
at windmills like i'm
you can see me the words fall out of my
mouth i challenge any of your mofos to a
mad joust
i got a big horse calling it a stallion
i'm dancing so skillfully like there's a
ballet on i make sure that my armor
protects
my face and my cheeks and my chin and my
neck i don't want to get a massive
wooden splinter
tearing my aorta letting it in there my
carotid pain
starts putting out blood cause the aim
of my opponent is so
damn good it goes in my neck and i fall
off my stallion
i'm like oh no i really fell on and when
i'm there
in the blood it's not clean in the mud i
look up and have a nice daydream
i'm feeling pain so apply the ointment
that's topical and while they heal me
i'd be thinking of the tropical place
that i can heal well
call the sea shell and then the doctor
says i can't hear well
can you make sure you repeat and say
well i pronounce it correctly
seychelles much better than those or
bahamas i daydream not a night
in my pajamas i do it when i'm picking
back there on the couch my wife looks at
me and says chris
you're a slouch i can vouch that you are
a potato i say i've got two tickets and
we're gonna
go she says no chris they don't hand to
me
it was a daydream it means it was a
fantasy and then we move out to a large
sports hall
we're having a tournament of nice
pickleball and if you've never learned
about it if it's never taught let me
tell you this you get half of
a tennis court you play laterally not a
portrait shape
you take a tiny net like a table tennis
one day
and then you pick up a wiffle ball and
then you go
serve and you just start out small it's
going back and forth
it never gets you in trouble there's no
volley in the seven foot line you play
doubles you gotta smash it down from
behind the line
if you play pickleball you'll enjoy
these lines you're like damn he's fine
when it comes to the fact but if you
want a job if you wanna go
back day after day like it's not your
fault then please never
commit any sexual assault or harassment
don't do the things to sandra don't
squeeze her on her ass
you shouldn't handle let her do her own
things without your pestering and
keeping your eyes fixed on her chest
it's so disgusting she'll take it
near or far she'll say come on chris
we're going in to hr
sitting down we're gonna try and mediate
but across the table
the ladies like great the best part of
my job is sending you down i'm gonna ask
what happened
look at me now did he touch you
inappropriately she cries and says yes
and you say yippy that's the best thing
yeah you know she's hot you comment on
it like a guy who was wearing a mascot
suit
at usc with the fighting trojans i only
learned that cause don mcmillan has
spoken about that
he was on here before he was an engineer
yet but i chose to ignore and if you
took the mask
the zero going up there they could fight
villains be heroes pressing up like
wonder woman
or superman they're going out to the big
sports stadium
and saying yeah score a field goal with
precision and then rip off the hat and
deploy laser vision
thank you so much for watching please do
like and subscribe and if you'd like to
see me at a live show which will be
starting back up
soon please do subscribe to my mailing
list the link is in the pinned comment
below